jews have been here in the united states
from early on
uh they didn't constitute a significant
presence at the start and they didn't
they didn't really constitute a
significant presence for quite a while
during colonial and revolutionary times
um what what really changed that it was
it was immigration
and it was not just immigration from you
know all over the world but from some
very specific places and that
that has to do with or that that leads
to the story of american judaism that we
think about today
we're not in this chapter we're not
going to get the whole picture when we
talk about denominations
you can speak in terms of
really five main denominations or
groupings of jews within the united
states reform orthodox
conservative that are talked about in
this chapter
and then reconstructionist and hasidic
which are not they're just mentioned but
not actually talked about in this
chapter
um so we're going to wait a little bit
to get to those groups
but before that comes on the scene we
have a first
distinction
the first jews in america are
sephardic jews
remember that there was that distinction
between the sephardic and the i always
misspell this term
the
ashkenazi or ashkenazic jews
um
do you remember the the
big difference between these two they
came from different places
where were the sephardic jews from
anyone remember offhand
i think i had a question about this on
the exam maybe many of you didn't answer
that one
anyone remember
spain
north africa
also netherland because they are holland
because they they went from spain to the
netherlands
and they were here first
and what did they try to do we talked
about this in an earlier chapter
blend in right
their synagogues were were built in such
a way that you could tell it's a
synagogue from the inside but not so
much from the outside
um where are these guys from
germany is in one big place where else
think about around what else is
bordering germany
go further east
poland at that time you know had ceased
to exist as a country
um it was divided between prussia and
austria and
russia one reason why the polish were so
sensitive about you know
like having their own representation
here in the united states because
when you don't have your own
representation sometimes you get you get
disappeared that way for poland where
else yeah
yeah that's part of germany um that's
southern germany some northern germans
might you know
some some northern germans who are kind
of biased think that barbarians aren't
truly german but
thankfully that's gone away mostly where
else
further further west or further east
sorry of uh poland let me get to
i could i could use the you know fiddler
on the roof
reference but i doubt that any of you
have seen that because it's such an old
musical
oh have you seen it okay well that's
good
um
do you remember where that was set uh no
what country no okay
what happens if you go further further
east of poland where do you get that
i'll give you a hint they're in the news
an awful lot
these last couple weeks
because uh
they're engaging in some
military maneuvers
that have got everybody worried
big country
exactly yeah so russia poland germany
lithuania also a lot of jews in
lithuania
and the ashkenazic jews are going to
come later on
through through immigration
now
the sephardic jews are
able to make it into the upper and upper
middle class
they're fairly americanized
they've blended in many of them have
been here for
generations by the time that the
ashkenazi jews are coming in and the
ashkenazi jews are coming in with much
less resources
many of them are actually
speaking a a dialect of german
called yiddish
it's kind of interesting
a lot of people
don't understand where yiddish comes
from yiddish is a dialect of german that
was spoken by
jews in in you know germany and in
lithuania
other areas because they've been going
east and for a long time there was so
much you know sort of anti-jewish
sentiment
that germans would say that they
couldn't understand yiddish if you take
younger germans and you have them here
yiddish they can recognize it
immediately as a dialect of german which
is what it is
so they're speaking a dialect
of
german that sets them apart because
they're not speaking english
they tend to be segregating themselves
into
where other
ashkenazi jews are are settling as well
so like it says communities of
successful ashkenazim and arisen in
american cities from atlanta to san
francisco they established synagogues
with rabbis
schools hospitals cemeteries
immediately after the civil war
american jewry tended to be urban german
descended english speaking public school
educated commercially oriented quite
prosperous
generally supportive of philanthropic
causes but then you have a vast influx
of eastern european jews so i'm talking
about ashkenazi jews from
eastern
europe
they're coming in with much less
resources they're coming in
not speaking english they're coming in
not being that that ready to to adapt
and what happens is there's kind of a
push on both sides
the jewish minority tends to you know
kind of close in on itself and there
tends to be a lot of anti-semitism
being brought into american culture bit
by bit by bit
you know the most virulent example of
this would be the ku klux klan
because the clan was against three
groups of people
remember
who are they
african-americans
who else
jews and
his men
well later on they they they take that
on but before that
who
that's much later on um that's like the
the clan of
of today
i'm thinking more like in the
late 1800s early 1920s when they had the
resurgence yeah
yeah because these were all seen as sort
of you know non-american foreign
um
part of it was about maintaining
uh segregation in place part of it was
about keeping the other out
that would be the most virulent form
that was kind of a fringe thing in most
places except for like in the 1920s and
1930s or in the south
but you have a lot of cases of
institutions that originally would allow
jews in
slowly erecting barriers and saying no
jews can't can apply here or we'll only
take so many jewish students
setting up quota systems things like
that so
what's going on there's there's a
dynamic that's happening in large part
because of the immigration
um
and your book
talks about um
the american jewish community begins to
organize efforts primarily in new york
why why new york
well because that's where you know
they're going to after ellis island
um
organized efforts helped the newcomers
orient themselves
although both groups are technically
ashkenazim the prosperous second and
third generation merchants who had
frequently adopted
the reform as as their denomination
were dismayed by the newly arrived
remote kins people they didn't like the
poverty the prevalence of yiddish
another thing you can say about
the the newer
ashkenazim coming from eastern europe
is that they were seen as
term that they use oriental meaning
eastern
meaning foreign
meaning kind of exotic
their services were seen as being kind
of strange
just to give you kind of an example of
this
a lot of the sephardim and the ashkenazi
would sort of establish themselves they
saw themselves as being more similar
in the way their services were run to
say american protestants where you're
very clearly delineated this is what
we're going to do now now we're in this
part of the service okay everyone shut
up because you know the minister is
going to preach a sermon that sort of
thing whereas
in a synagogue
um for you know some of these
these newer immigrants people would be
milling around
you know doing whatever
going in and going out
you know it was seen as kind of strange
kind of unorganized kind of
typically
you use the term that they they use
there
typically
eastern
so
what ends up happening is there's a
division that takes place within the
jewish community
and
if we get away from these
ethnic things and we talk in terms of uh
ideologies
or ways of uh living out judaism
reform judaism comes
and reform judaism
was based in the enlightenment
the same enlightenment that religious
liberalism that we've looked at before
was based in as well
and what it tended to do
was to say that judaism
was an
ethical religion
to downplay
what they saw as the ceremonial aspects
so you know think about the jewish law
the torah as we've talked about before
613 commandments
um
some of them are pretty you know
closely tied into morals like don't kill
people
don't take bribes you know um don't move
your neighbors boundary markers to take
over their land those sorts of things
some of them
uh
are hard to figure out how you would
adapt to modern life like the you know
things about your tent getting leprosy
um
there are laws about that what to do if
a tent gets you know these swatches on
it some of them have to do with things
like when you can actually have sex
when you can't have sex some of them
have to do with what you can eat what
you can't eat we've talked about the the
kosher laws the kashruts
there's a lot of prohibitions
there's a lot of things that have to be
done a certain way
and reformed jews were willing to say
well that stuff we can get rid of
that's no longer binding
the
you know
torah has to be interpreted
in terms of what modern life requires
um
so like it says reform is one of the
first of american jewish traditions to
adapt itself to the american
denominational pattern
and how did they do so so they they
sought their model in contemporary
protestant practice
and they adopted innovations like
seating families together in pews in
other synagogues the men would be seated
on one side the women in another place
families would be split apart
using organs and choirs discontinuing
the wearing of traditional marks like
the you know what's called often called
the skull cap yamaka
warn you know warn
why
because it's a mark of pioneering or
wearing prayer shawls right all of that
would be
stuff that's just ceremonial and so they
thought you need to get rid of that that
no longer
that's not modern that doesn't fit in
they they quit using hebrew and started
using german or english
so
they started this as a
change in in practice a change in
liturgy change in the way the service
went
and then they wanted to think of this in
terms of something more coherent an
ideology
a way of seeing
the world and understanding the religion
that's where this focus on
ethics
as what the religion was really about
came in
the role of the rabbi changed from that
of the traditional scholar of the torah
and talmud to something more like a
typical protestant minister preacher
counselor and administrator
so
this is what the
the
the elite essentially
who are already established this is what
they gravitated towards it was more
american more typical
what do you think happens is a reaction
can everybody fit into this this
framework
well what if you believe that the torah
has to be followed
down to the letter
what if you don't want your services to
be in english and you want them to be in
hebrew
what if you think that the ceremonial
stuff really matters
that's where
on the other hand
judaism comes about originally orthodox
is actually a bad word
that the reformers are calling these
stick-in-the-mud conservative
rabbis and congregations who want to
keep doing things the old-fashioned way
they are
traditional and hold on to the
traditions they believe that the
torah with all 613
commandments
is to be followed
the services are to remain in hebrew
as much as possible the rabbi is
supposed to
continue on being a scholar of talmud
and torah and the
most importantly well not most
importantly but you know most
distinctively
keeping kosher
following the ritual codes
about what can be eaten what can't be
eaten how things have to be slaughtered
is continued
and your book talks about you know if
you ever go and you like there's a
number of different kosher
signifiers that you can find for foods
your book talks about a banquet that's
held by
the reformed jews and it may have been a
catering mistake or it may have been
something deliberate they serve things
and this becomes a dividing line they
serve things that will violate the
kosher law like shrimp
so
you know could you step across that line
and enter this or were you going to
stick with that that divided them a
third
originally sort of mediating
group were the conservative jews
and they're sort of a middle way between
reform and orthodox
the conservative
they want to fit themselves in between
these two
he had to combine what's what's best in
both there's a sense of participation
in tradition
but
adapted
with
each
generation
they leave it up to the the
congregations to decide how they want to
interpret the torah how they want to
interpret
the ceremonial requirements and some are
more
conservative in that that sense and some
are others they emphasize home-centered
rituals and the role of the family
most of them keep kosher but this is not
universal
the law
or the torah
is taken seriously
but adapted
and um
another a couple other things that they
that are distinctive about them is is
the the having the synagogue center a
combination house of worship with
facilities for education
recreation and other community
activities
seeing jewish life is something holistic
so you've got these three
major groups
and
conservative conservative jews kind of
fluctuated back and forth one of the
real dividing lines between them uh
reformed jews
they have female rabbis
and that that follows pretty you know
consistently from these enlightenment
ideas you know no distinction between
sexes
of that sort that's not going to fly for
orthodox jews
conservative jews adopted
that plank of having female rabbis and
that was a really decisive break between
the conservatives and the orthodox
because the orthodox don't actually
recognize
female rabbis from conservative
congregations as being rabbis
but they don't recognize many other
rabbis male or females being rabbis
because they don't have the same uh
training and standards as as the
orthodox but there was at least some
reciprocity there
so
these are three of the main
denominations
we haven't talked about hasidic jews yet
who play a major role in american
judaism today
because of immigration and we haven't
talked about this this very small group
that actually broke off in the
conservatives called the
reconstructionist jews but these are
three of the major
denominations the three
three major ways of living out judaism
here in america the ones that had a big
role in the early 20th and mid-20th
century
as judaism made its way into the
mainstream
so that's where we got